سحب وزير الثقافه الاسرائيلي فيلما
تمثيليا يظهر اسيانا للاوامر داخل الجيش
ويشير الفيلم الى الخلاف بشان تغيرات
قضائيه مقترحه بوصفها سببا لشق وحده
المؤسسه العسكريه وتصر حكومه نتنياهو على
اقرار تغييرات تحد من صلاحيات القضاء
لصالح السلطه التنفيذيه ما ادى الى
احتجاجات الغير مسبوقه وتحذيرات من احتمال
حرب اهليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى اي
مدى اقتربت اسرائيل من شبح الحرب الاهليه
بسبب الخلاف المتصاعد بشان التغييرات
القضائيه وما يرافقها من مظاهرات ودعوات
للعصيان داخل الجيش
وكيف ستنعكس المواجهه داخل اسرائيل على
سياسات حكومه نتنياهو تجاه الفلسطينيين
وما مستقبلها في ضوء تمسكها بانفاذ
التغييرات القضائيه
وباي عين تنظر واشنطن لما يجري في اسرائيل
خاصه مع تصاعد الانتقادات داخل اداره
بايدن من جنوح نتنياهو بالبلاد الى اقصى
اليمين بما يؤثر على علاقات البلدين
[موسيقى]
فيلم تمثيلي اجز مزيدا من الجدل بشان
التغييرات القضائيه في اسرائيل قصته قائد
طائره حربيه يرفض تغطيه كتيبه من المشاه
اثناء نشاط عسكري على خلفيه المواقف من
خطه نتنياهو احداث تغييرات تحد من صلاحيات
القضاء لصالح الحكومه
كثيرون حذروا من تداعيات الاستقطاب الذي
يحتد في البلاد فمع الانقسام الساخن في
الشارع بات عصيان الاوامر داخل الجيش
القاصي والداني وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
اكدت اعلان اكثر من الف عنصر من وحدات
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي وقف خدمتهم في
الاحتياط رفضا للتعديلات القضائيه موقع
وانا الاسرائيلي وصف الخطوه بالهزه
الارضيه في صفوف سلاح الجو ما سيؤثر حتما
على نشاطه كان نترياه قد قال انه لا يعقل
ان تستمر مجموعه داخل الجيش في رفض
الاوامر وتعطيل عمل الحكومه المنتخبه اما
زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه فقد اشار مؤخرا
الى ان حكومه نتنياهو وسياساتها تقود
اسرائيل الى الكارثه وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي السابق بنجانس كان الاشد صراحه
في التحذير من تداعيات الازمه قائلا ان
نتنياهو يقود اسرائيل الى حرب اهليه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تل ابيب
الدكتور دان شيفتان رئيس برنامج دراسات
الامن القومي في جامعه حيفا ومن واشنطن
ديفيد
المستشار السابق لشؤون الامن القوميه
الامريكي وعضو مكتب جو بايدن عندما كان
سيناتوران من الناصره معنا السيد ايهاب
جبارين المحلل السياسي والباحث المختص في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه مرحبا بكم جميعا وابدا
بالسيد شفتان هل رد الفعل سيد شفتان الذي
حدث في اسرائيل على هذا الفيلم الذي نشره
الوزير كان مبالغا فيه ام ان هناك ما خوف
حقيقيه فعلا من مساله الحرب الاهليه كما
قال معرضون نتنياه
لا اعتقد ان الحرب الاهليه هي
احتمال في اسرائيل لدينا مساله جدليه
لدينا ازمه لدينا صراع على السلطه في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولكن كل ذلك يتم من
ضمن الاطر الدبلوم الديمقراطيه بمعنى اخر
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه هي اقوى من قبل
لانه بالرغم من هذه المواجهات كل شيء يحصل
من دون اعمال عنف وهناك التزام من كلا
الطرفين بالعمليات الديمقراطيه طبعا هناك
الكثير من الديماغوجيه واستخدام
البروباجندا من الطرفين ولكن
المواجهه هي حقيقيه ولكنها لا تهدد
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه اذا لم تكن هذه
الاحداث تهدد الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه
لماذا اذا فزع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستنت رودو وارسل
كلاهما رسائل الى اسرائيل مفادها ان
الديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه في خطر وان
العلاقات بين البلدين
بين امريكا تحديدا وبين اسرائيل ربما لا
تكون كسابق عهدها بين ديمقراطي دائرتين
مستقرتين على مدى الخمسه وسبعين سنه
الماضيه
اعتقد ان هذه هذا تحدي للديمقراطيه
والرئيس بايدن والتعليقاته
ايضا تبين ان هناك باعث قلق مهمه هنا نرى
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
وايضا طيله فتره
حياه السياسيه يتغير ويتحول الى اليمين
واقصى اليمين والى التطرف طبعا نعرف عنه
ذلك انه كان يتعامل مع القضيه الفلسطينيه
ومع الضفه الغربيه بطريقه عدوانيه
وشديده لكن هذه المره نحن نتحدث عن تعامله
مع قضيه داخليه وتشريعات منتظره والمحكمه
العليا وهم يقبلون في الكنيسه سينتهون الى
قرار قبل
فتره الاستراحه واعتقد ان الوزير لينكن
والرئيس يراقبان هذا الامر عن كثب في ذهاب
جبارين ماء الداعي لهذه الضجه في اسرائيل
يعني في نهايه المطاف او في التحليل
الاخير بنيامين نتنياهو رئيس حكومه منتخب
ويريد ان يؤدي واجباته طبعا في توصيفه
للازمه واجباته على نحو الذي يراه ملائما
للدوله الاسرائيليه فكيف يعني كيف يسوغ
معارضوه نتنياهو وجهه نظرهم على هذا النحو
العنيف من ان رئيس منتخب يريد ان يمارس
صلاحيته
نعم بدون ان نشكر ان هنالك يعني حتى من
طرف المعارضين ينظروا لكل ما يجري في داخل
هذه الحكومه هو محاوله لاخذ الصهيونيه الى
المرحله التاليه الصهيونيه الدينيه البحته
على مدار 75 عام الصهيونيه في اسرائيل
كانت تدار بما يعني يسمى
وعاء صهر لهذه الصهيونيه
بدمج ما بين اليهوديه والديمقراطيه على حد
سواء طبعا يتعلق عمن نتحدث او الديمقراطيه
اتجاه من هذا طبعا كان كله صحيح اتجاه
اليهودي في داخل اسرائيل الان وفق هذه
المعادله المعادله صارت على مدى 75 عام في
خضون الخمسه وسبعون عام كان هنالك عده
محاولات وهنا نقطه ربما هي مهمه جدا في
نهايه المطاف هذه الصهيونيه وهذه البلوره
من كرسها ومن بناها في نهايه المطاف نحن
نتحدث عن اليسار الاسرائيلي الكلاسيكي ان
شئنا الهجناء بمفهومها مفهوم الجيش انذاك
والان على غضون كل هذه السنوات كان هنالك
محاولات لليمين على عده محاولات وعلى عده
محطات في محاوله لقلب او دمج نفسه في داخل
الحكم في داخل اسرائيل المحاوله الاولى
التي نجحت كانت في اواخر سنوات السبعين
عندما
صعد الى الحكم ولربما احد اهم الماخذ التي
تحتسب على من قبل اليمين انه اي نعم صعد
الى الحكم لكنه لم يجري ثوره
مراكز السلطه ومراكز اتخاذ القرار في داخل
اسرائيل وتركها في يد اليسار الكلاسيكي
مطاي والهجنه
السابقون ان صح القول والان ومنذ تلك
الفتره او على الاقل لم تكن هنالك الكثير
من المحاولات بين يمين نتنياهو حتى عندما
صعد الى الحكم في المره الاولى في عام 96
97 حتى عام 2000 لم يحاول بتاتا المس في
قواعد اللعبه
الصهيونيه في داخل اسرائيل ولربما عندما
استوعب بين يمينه نياهو ان هذا كان السبب
الاول لخسارته الحكم انذاك عندما عاد في
2009 كان لديه هدف واحد بسط سيطره اليمين
والنفوذه بشكل كامل على كل مراسم الحكم في
داخل اسرائيل وهذا تحديدا ما يؤرق منام
المحتجون في داخل تل ابيب وهي نقطه يجب ان
نقف عندها منذ عام 2018 وحتى هذه المرحله
نحن نتحدث قرابه الخمس سنوات لا يوجد
هنالك استقرار سياسي في نهايه المطاف
الحديث ليس فقط عن سته اسابيع سته اشهر
عفوا الحديث عن سته اعوام اسرائيل موجوده
في حاله بلبله سياسيه بالكامل هذا هذا هذه
نقطه مهمه دكتور الشفتان الى اي مدن يمكن
ان يؤثر او تؤثر هذه البلبله وهذا التوتر
الذي وصل حتى الى المؤسسه العسكريه
وف هم من هذه الرساله الاخيره انه تمرد من
قبل ضباط الجيش الى اي مدن سيؤثر على
سياسات اسرائيل المختلفه وبالاخص سياساتها
تجاه الفلسطينيه
في البدايه ما من تاثيرا لهذا على
الفلسطينيين باي شكل من الاشكال ما من
اهتماما من قبل الفلسطينيين لا بالحكومه
ولا بالمعارضه وايضا لا نتحدث هنا عن
عصيان هناك اشخاص يتطوعون للخدمه العسكريه
هم كبار سنا لا يمكن ان يعودوا الى الخدمه
العسكريه تتطوعون حتى في الخمسينات
عذرا للمقاطعه هناك معطى جديد للتو ظهر
على شاشاتنا الان وهو خبر عاجل نقلا عن
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه اذ يطالب
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بوقف التعديلات
القضائيه المقترحه بسبب الاستقالات التي
حدثت او بعد موجه الاستقالات التي حدثت في
صفوف ضباط الاحتياط ووصف الوضع بانه مقلق
تفضل دكتور شفتان بناء على هذا المعطى
الجديد او هذا الخبر العاجل الا يؤثر ذلك
على بنيه الدوله الاسرائيليه وسياسه
اسرائيل بصفه عامه تجاه او بصفه خاصه تجاه
الفلسطينيه
كلا في البدايه ما من استقالات نتحدث عن
اشخاص تطوعوا في السابق وسحبوا تطوعا هذا
امر جدي ولكننا لا نتحدث عن استقالات
بالاضافه الى ذلك نحن نعرف ما قاله وزير
الدفاع قال دعونا نؤجل هذه الامور لايام
لم يقل دعونا ننتهي من هذه التعديلات على
تشريعات ولكن النقطه المهمه هنا هي انهم
لا يتحدثون عن مواجهه يمكن ان تقود
الهيكليه الاسرائيليه او النظام
الاسرائيلي الحكومه تقول نحن لدينا
الصلاحيه لاننا كسبنا في الانتخابات
المعارضه تقول لدينا الحق بان نتظاهر ضد
الحكومه ولا نقبل قرارات الحكومه هذا ما
يحصل في الديمقراطيات الديمقراطيه ليست
نظام يتم الات فيه بين كل الفرقاء هو نظام
عندما يكون هناك اختلافات في وجهات النظر
هناك محدوديه للسبل المستخدمه نعم هي ازمه
حقيقيه نعم هل تقود النظام كلا هل تؤثر
على الفلسطينيين ابدا ابدا ما من احدا
يهتم بالقضيه الفلسطينيه اليوم لا
الائتلاف ولا المعارضه اذا محاوله ربط هذا
الموضوع احاول ان اشرح خلال الاسئله
التاليه لماذا طرحنا هذا السؤال دعني
انتقل الى واشنطن
والسؤال للسيد ديفيد سيد ديفيد
هل تعتقد ان هذه الازمه ستمكن الرئيس جو
بايدن من الضغط على نتنياهو بشان تعديل
سياساته ودفعه اكثر نحو الاعتدال ام ان
نتنياهو سياخذها على انها معركه تدفعه
اكثر الى اليمين المتشدد والمتطرف في
اسرائيل طبعا انت تدري الفرق بين الاعتدال
والتطرف تجاه الفلسطينيين من خلال
السياسات العامه للدوله الاسرائيليه
ان ارد على السيد الذي تحدث للتو اعتقد ان
كل شيء له علاقه بالقضيه الفلسطينيه هذا
لا يحدث في فراغ
وكذلك فانما ينظر فيها للكنيست هو تحديد
او تقليد او تجميد المحكمه العليا من
القيامه
باجراءات تجاهها اذرع الدوله الاخرى هذا
شيء فيه تشدد وفيه خطر وهذا فيه افراط في
الامور الرئيس
بايتن لا يحاول ان يفرض نفوذه على رئيس
وزراء
نتنياهو لكن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي لن
يفوت فرصه
ليميل اكثر الى اليمين ليست هل سيفعل ذلك
ام لا بل متى سيفعل ذلك اعتقد ان موقفه
موقف سيء وهو يحتاج الى ان تكون له
استجابه مختلفه واكثر ليس فقط تجاه
الولايات المتحده بل تجاه المنطقه عموما
لان اسرائيل لا تستطيع تحمل اي ازمه
داخليه بهذا الحجم كيف نفهم السؤال لك يا
سيد ديفيد كيف نفهم الرساله التي مررها
الرئيس جو بايدن من خلال الكاتب توماس
فريدمان في صحيفه نيويورك تايمز من ان بيض
قد يكون اخر رئيس ديمقراطي يؤيد اسرائيل
بهذه الصوره او تتمتع اسرائيل في عهده
بهذا التاييد المطلق كيف نفهم هذه الرساله
هل هناك ازمه حقيقيه في العلاقات بين
واشنطن
لا لا اعتقد ان الامر كذلك ولا اعتقد ان
توم فريد من رغم انه
براسل له قيمته لكنه احيانا
يذهب بعيدا اكثر مما ينبغي الرئيس بايدن
والحزب الديمقراطي دعم قوي لاسرائيل
واعتقد ان الرئيس سوف يستمر بهذا الدعم
بالتاكيد ستكون هناك بعض التغييرات حول
فيما يتعلق كيف سنستمر بالدعم المالي
لاسرائيل وامور المتعلقه بالموازنه لكن لا
اعتقد ان الحزب الديمقراطي لن يتخلى ابدا
عن دعمه لاسرائيل سيد جبارين ما رايك انت
بخصوص لدى تاثر القضيه الفلسطينيه بهذه
الازمه الداخليه الاسرائيليه
بنظر هذا السؤال الاهم لانه في نهايه
المطاف عندما نتحدث نحن عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو
اذ كنت قد تحدثت عن وعاء السهر
للاسرائيليه كان يحدث دائما في داخل الجيش
هو كان هذا الوعاء على يعني هنا يجب ان
نفهم نقطه مهمه جدا المجتمع الاسرائيلي
اسرائيل التي تمارس سياسات فوق تصد هي
كذلك تمارسها اتجاه مجتمعاتها في الداخل
كل المجتمعات الاسرائيليه متفوقه نقطه
الالتقاء الاولى يعني حتى في داخل المدارس
هنالك مدارس تقريبا لكل مجتمع من
المتدينين من الحديدين من العلمانيين
تقريبا لكل فئه هنالك مدارسها وصبغتها
التعليميه نقطه الالتقاء الاولى عاده ما
كانت تكون في الجيش الان وهي نقطه مهمه
جدا ماذا كان يحدث في الجيش على مدار 50
عام تقريبا حتى عام 2000 من سيطر على
جيشهم الهجناء او خروجيه الهجناء بكلمات
اخرى بكلمات اذاك اليسار والمباي وحتى كنا
نرى اهميه تفاعل ذلك حتى
فيما بعد ذلك وخروج الكثير من رؤساء هيئه
الاركان الى عالم السياسه يعني الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي على مدى 50 عاما الاولى من
تاريخها كان مليء بخريجه
الجيش الاحتلال الى داخل هذه الركنه الان
ما حدث ما حرب لبنان الدي ان ايه في داخل
الجيش الاسرائيلي تغير كليا بكل مفهوم
الكلمه او بكلمات اضاف بات اكثر هنالك من
معتمري القلنسوات المتدينون في داخل الجيش
بدات نسبتهم تزيد وبات لديهم هنالك سيطره
في نهايه المطاف على الجيش وبنايه المطاف
معتمني القلنسوات لديهم مشروع استيطاني
باحث وهنا نقطه يجب ان نقف عندها
رئيس هيئه الاركان الحالي هو معتمر قلنسوه
سابقه ومتدين سابق اي بكلمات اخرى باتت
هذه الفئات الفئات التي لطالما كانت
محسوبه وفق المسميات الاسرائيليه اسرائيل
الثانيه او الطبقه الثانيه من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي باتت اكثر فاكثر تسيطر على
الاقل على داخل
الجيش اذا اردنا ان نترجم هذا الكلام الى
واقع عملي في حياه الفلسطينيين يعني ذلك
مزيدا من الاستيطان
[موسيقى]
بالضبط وهذا في نهايه المطاف ما تمارسها
اسرائيل على ارض الواقع في نهايه المطاف
هذا ما نراه في العشرون عام الاخير في
العشرون عام الاخير كل معادله الاستيطان
اختلفت جنود الاحتلال باتوا حتى يعني وهذا
مناعه في
الاعتداءات الاخيره وعدوان المستوطنين
الاخير باتوا مجرد سكنات حمايه للمستوطنين
وليس فعلا يقومون بواجبهم العسكري اتجاه
من يحتلون فبالتالي هذا ما تواضحه وهذه هي
المعادله وهنا ربما النقطه يجب ان نقف
عندها في نهايه المطاف يتعلق بالحرب
الاهليه في داخل اسرائيل هنالك خطين
باختصار هنالك خطين حمر اثنين لطالما بقيه
اللعبه في داخل اسرائيل ما بينهما هي
بعيده عن الحرب الاهليه الخط الاول الاحمر
الاول هو الاغتيالات السياسيه والخط
الثاني ليس العصيان المدني وهذا لاحظ مهم
جدا العصيان الذي نراه الان هو محسوب على
جنود الاحتياط بكلمات اخرى السابق
الامر الحقيقي
الذي ممكن ان ياخذنا الى حرب اهليه هو
حاله التمرد في داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي
دكتور شفتان بقي على عطله الكنيست اقل من
اسبوعين اقل من عشره ايام حتى وفي خلال
الايام القليله المقبله سينظر بشكل نهائي
في مصير التعديلات القضائيه المقترحه من
قبل الائتلاف الحكومي اي افق ينتظر هذه
الازمه في ضوء اصرار نتنياهو على موقفه
وكذلك اصرار المعارضه الاسرائيليه على
مواقفها وحشد الشارع والتوتر داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه
لدينا محاولات في اللحظات الاخيره ودقائق
الاخيره للتخفيف من هذه التعديلات بالنسبه
الى التشريعات لا نعرف ما اذا نجحت ام لا
ولكن هل يمكن ان نعود لاحقا الى هذه
المناقشات بالنسبه الى الجوهر
الاختلافات ليست كبيره
الطرفان يقولان انها كبيره ولكن في
الحقيقه ليست كبيره يمكن التوصل الى اتفاق
في الاراء هناك اتفاق في الاراء بالنسبه
الى ضروره الاصلاحات على المستوى القضائي
وعدد كبير من الاسرائيليين اليها ودون
اصلاحات راديكاليه عدد او معظم
الاسرائيليين يودون ان يصلوا الى توافق
وطني تجري في اطاره الاصلاحات بشكل مقبول
من قبل الجميع هذه الازمه سوف تنتهي عندما
كان تحاول
تخفيف من وقع هذه الازمه او تخفيف وصف
حدتها لكن الفيلم الذي نشره الوزير
الاسرائيلي واضطر الى سحبه كان يقول غير
ذلك بالمره كان يتحدث عن طيار ضابط في
الطائره يعني يتشاور مع كتيبه من المشاه
وعندما يعرف انهم مختلفين معه في الراي
فانه يقوم بقصف هذه الكتيبه وهذا حدث ضخم
كيف كيف ترى ان الازمه التي انتجت فيلما
كهذا هي ازمه بسيطه ومخففه بهذه الدرجه
نعم ولكن هذا الامر ليس الحقيقه هذا جزء
من البروباجاندا التي يلجا اليها الناس
لكي يقولوا اننا لا نود ذلك في الجيش هذا
فيلم هناك ديماغوجيه في الخطابات في
الطرفين هذه هي السياسه وهذه هي
الديمقراطيه يكذب الجميع من اجل المضي
قدما
بالاجنده الخاصه بهم وبالتالي يجب ان لا
نرى ان هذا الفيلم يمثل الحقيقه على مستوى
الجيش الاسرائيلي
ما حدود الضغوط الامريكيه او التاثير
الامريكي على قرار نتنياهو خلال الايام
القليله المتبقيه قبل عطله الكنيست في
تقديرك هل يمضي قدما في ضغوطها او في
مناشداته للحكومه الاسرائيليه بالتعقل ام
يرفع يديه وكفى مكان
الرئيس
وادارته مع طوني بلنكن بصفته وزيرا
للخارجيه ومستشار الامن القومي ومجلس
الامن القومي لن يتخلى ابدا عن بيبي
نتنياهو كرئيس وزراء اسرائيل لكن هناك حذر
كما كما اشار
السابق قبل قليل
الديمقراطيه ليست دائما لطيفه وجميله هناك
اناس كما ذكرتم
هم
يحتاجون هذا ضمن الاطار ونطاق
الديمقراطيه لكنها هذه الاحتجاجات اذا ما
تصاعدت في ايامي وليالي الصيف الساخنه هذه
بحيث اصبح الاخ يقف ضد اخيه عند ذاكسا
نواجه مشكله حقيقيه واعتقد ان في كل اعضاء
حكومه
الامريكيه
السابق لشؤون الامن القومي الامريكي وعضو
مكتب جو بايدن عندما كان عضوا في مجلس
الشيوخ كان معنا من واشنطن واشكر كذلك
ضيفنا من تل ابيب الدكتور دان شيفتان رئيس
برنامج دراسات الامن القومي في جامعه حيفا
ومن الناصره كان معنا السيد ايهاب جبارين
المحلل السياسي والباحث المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه شكرا لكم
انتهت حلقتنا في امان الله
[موسيقى]